hey guys how's it going so today i
wanted to show you something because the
internet has been kind of going crazy
over the design similarities of the
original iphone and the new apple watch
and it's been at least a week since i've
talked about the apple watch so here we
are i just can't stop talking about it
because i really i really do like it a
lot but i also really
really loved the original iphone it's
kind of crazy because in the whole
writing process of my book everything
kind of goes back to the turning point
of when i got this phone it was at that
point that sort of that whole viral
video of the iphone bill happened was
when i realized how powerful the
internet was and basically made me say
remember when i quit my job mom and you
told me i shouldn't quit yeah i probably
shouldn't have quit but it's okay
because everything all works out the
book is out june 2nd which is kind of
crazy because that's so soon there's a
link in the description if you guys want
to pre-order and if you've already
pre-ordered it thank you guys and i
can't wait because we're going to be
doing some fun little contests coming up
soon but the whole reason of this video
i'm getting off tangent was to show you
guys the similarities of these two
devices and this is actually gonna be
the first time that i've removed one of
these bands it's pretty simple if you
haven't done it before you just press
down this button and i haven't actually
done it before so i'm hoping that it's
as simple as i think it's gonna be oh
well
pretty simple look at you
you are like a mini original
iphone this is just crazy so now this is
the aluminum
apple watch so i'm sure the steel will
look even more similar to this one
look at you you little nugget of love
look at this it's almost the same
thickness which is kind of crazy because
this aluminum one is super light this is
the 38 millimeter and the 42 and
probably
not probably definitely is slightly
bigger
look at you
look at whoa homie put yourself back
down
so that's uh it's kind of crazy let me
know what you guys think about
these similarities
i loved you
i still love you it's not like
i don't love you any longer it's just
i've moved on
to smaller thank you guys for watching i
will see you in my next video and if you
haven't yet pre-ordered my book and you
want to please check it out in the link
in the description or go to
ijustinebook.com i am getting really
excited about it really coming out it's
kind of crazy that it's it's almost here
you guys want to read the first chapter
i will also put a link in the
description where there's a sample book
and you'll be able to read the first
chapter and i think it's the intro as
well so check it out i love you i'll see
you in my next video bye
you